you mentioned that you moved to la for a
period of time which seems like every
artist does at some point in time now
um
is was that something that was like
beneficial to you because i feel like
sometimes people come to la just because
it's the thing to do it was it was it
was i say 50 50. when i came out here we
came out here you know saying just due
to that was the beginning of my [ __ ] got
[ __ ] up when i came to la that was
when my [ __ ] was getting rocky and
landing all my management and all that
[ __ ]
ugly that's why i originally left like
all right
[ __ ] this let me get away from this let
me get out of here you know what i'm
saying then we came to l.a doing la [ __ ]
lit
partying right you know what i'm saying
get lost in the lifestyle till you know
saying we look back at atlanta we about
a year and a half at la light
then what the [ __ ] somebody else popping
or somebody up like you know what i'm
saying that [ __ ] don't ever stop you
know saying around this time 21 savage
is bubbling yeah yeah so we're like oh
it's a whole new [ __ ] vibe coming
through the city yeah i'm saying
and you could tell the energy was
different between you know saying people
that we once was cool with so we had to
pack our [ __ ] up in l.a as he save a lot
of money on rent
boy yeah
went back to atlanta you know what i'm
saying kiss the babies you know what i'm
saying did did you know i'm saying all
the other relationships that was
[ __ ] up right
brought them back together the best way
we could